hello everyone
good afternoon uh it gives me great
pleasure to
invite you all to our discussion
session a more in-depth discussion of
the talk we heard yesterday from dr
elise 12
and as part of the infant's colloquium
series as many of you know
we have these two events we have the
talk followed by
a more open discussion um
with the issues that were raised in the
talk and
yesterday dr 12 talked to us about
causal ordering and in particular
the many thorny issues that come
together
when one is trying to understand quantum
entanglement
and the role of causal ordering in um
understanding quantum mechanics more
generally and she presented some new
ideas
uh new um new avenues that she's been
thinking
about on on this problem and it gives me
great
pleasure today that our discussant and
conversant with her
we have professor yamima ben menehem
from the department of philosophy at the
hebrew university of jerusalem
yamiba ben meneheme is the barbara drews
dibner professor
of the history of science emeritus at
hebrew university of jerusalem
and a lecturer in the department of
philosophy and jewish talk
shalom college professor ben manahem to
those of you who are familiar with the
intellectual currents in the philosophy
of science
would know that needs no introduction
she's one of the preeminent philosophers
of science whose work has spent
causation the interpretation of quantum
mechanics scientific realism
the role of contingency and necessity in
history so a real broad palette
of really important and complex problems
that she has worked on
um and so she is the perfect
uh conversant from whom we can learn
a lot uh about how to think about these
sort of
radical new ways that elise presented
yesterday for us to engage
with the concept of entitlement
um professor ben menehem's recent book
titled causation in science published in
2018
is is truly remarkable so if anyone is
looking for a primer
to get to speed on matters of causation
in science more broadly including the
many open
questions and debates i highly recommend
the book
and before i turn the floor over
to yamima i would like to invite you and
remind you all
to keep your video switched off and just
a quick reminder on the format
we will seat the floor to professor ben
meneham
after which um you know elise
and she will engage with
going through further points of
clarification and debate
and then we open up to the floor for a
general q a
so without further ado um
i would like to turn it over to uma
thank you so much thank you very much
freya for this invitation and thank you
hi
um and the people who are here with us
and um i'm really grateful
um to alice for introducing and i
suppose
many of us are um for introducing us to
really
cutting-edge thinking in the foundations
and experimentation in front thinking
and experimentation in the foundations
of
quantum mechanics
um actually i won't
be discussing a
superposition of causal
states and processes that she presented
to us
yesterday but i want to step back
a little bit and go back first to
a few words about quantum mechanics and
then
step back even further and talk a little
more
about causation so
quantum mechanics is mind-boggling right
we all
know that and um the price we have to
pay well the benefits are enormous too
because it's
the most successful theory ever but
the intellectual price we have to pay
seems to rise
with every new generation of researchers
looking into it
because at the beginning we only thought
okay
schredinger's function doesn't describe
a wave in three-dimensional space
it's a probability wave okay so
maybe we have to give up determinism but
that's
not such a high price
um but then it turned out that there are
much more serious problems
and uh one of them and perhaps
the most serious problem as elise noted
yesterday is the problem of
um entanglement and the reason it is
such
an engaging problem and such a difficult
problem is that
it threatens to get us into conflict
with a special theory of relativity
which no one really wants to give up
so this is the major problem there are
the problems the measurement problem
other problems
and there are various solutions to it
and none of them
completely satisfies everyone as yet
but i want to go back for a minute to
entanglement and how it came i have to i
thought i was sharing this screen
so we have the uncertainty principle and
einstein and
and his colleagues budolskin rosen was
looking
at this uncertainty principle which
gives us a kind
of limit on what we can measure or how
precisely we can prepare a system
but there was a camp in
mainly the copenhagen camp who said no
this is a much more serious constraint
and it has a limit on um
not only the precision that we can
measure something not only as the
precision that we can prepare a system
but
on the actual existence of these
variables
and there are certain pairs of variables
and
initially and we here too can talk about
a position and momentum so what was
and and if we have only one particle and
we're going to measure its position how
are we going to prove that it didn't
have a momentum at the same time
we cannot do that because when we
measure position as heisenberg showed we
interfere with the momentum and so we
cannot prove that the uncertainty
principle is really such
a strong constraint on reality
so the ingenious idea was to take this
system and have two particles instead of
one particle and then at the beginning
they start from a position which we can
signify this designate by zero
and zero momentum as well and then
there is some interaction that sends
them into
reverse directions and
now the story begins we can either
measure position and then the other
party would know
and i'm specifically not specifying at
the moment
why the other party would also know
what position the particle is in
although
no measurement was carried out on the
other side but we could
also measure momentum and the other
party would know
and since we didn't interfere with
anything that the other party did
einstein and colleagues concluded
that both position and momentum
exist and the only limitation of the
uncertainty principle
is on measurement
okay why do i go to that problem
i go back to that problem because
already here
why why is it that we assume
that the momentum of one particle has to
be correlated with it
of the other particle because there is a
conservation law here
so already here we touch on something
that according to my approach and
i will say more about it later is
related
to causality now
as thinking about that developed a lot
of things had to happen first of all
here we have continuous variables and
translated it into discrete variables
which would lead to measurement
then famously bell translated it or not
translated it but
reformulated the problem when we don't
only measure
variables in one direction but we play
around with the correlations in
different directions like
three different spin measurements in
different directions
and moreover
it turned out that we can send these
particles initially
turned out that in theory we could do
that we can
send these particles so far away in
space-time that they are
as we say space-time related and they
cannot
interact with one another according to
the special theory of relativity
and then the correlation becomes really
mysterious
because how are we to explain
that correlation they cannot signal to
one another
because we thought to it that they are
so far away so the only other
possibility is that there is a common
cause
to this correlation the only other
possibility
given our classical way of thinking when
we have correlation
then either one
is the cause of the other or the other
is the cause of the first
or if that cannot happen if there cannot
be a direct connection between the two
we are looking for a common cause for
that correlation
and the big achievement of bell's
inequalities
was to rule out the possibility of such
a common cause
in this context we call the common cause
hidden variables because
supposedly there are some additional
variables that determine
what would be the result of a
measurement on each one of the particles
in each one of the directions that we
choose to measure
so instead of common cause we're talking
about hidden variable
variables but it amounts to the same
thing
and so if there
is no common cause then we are back to
the problem of correlation
so maybe they do signal to one another
but that would mean that we have we are
violating the special theory of
relativity
so this is a big conundrum and
as conundrums are sometimes solved
there is a distinction these states can
be
correlated but they cannot signal to one
another
and this is a new idea because again
classically we would
think that the correlation lets us
allows us to infer from what happens to
one what happened to the other
but in this case we say correlation
yes signaling no so it's a new way
of understanding the correlation in
order to save compatibility between
quantum mechanics and the special theory
of relativity
now the special theory of relativity as
you remember
is a causal theory in a very strong
sense because there is a limitation
on how causal signals signals
can travel they can travel at a certain
speed
not faster than the speed of light and
therefore
it is causality
that divides space space time into
regions where events in those regions
can interact with one another causally
and
regions that where events cannot
interact with one another causally and
moreover
in those events in those areas of space
time
where there is no causal interaction
there
is no well-defined temporal order
so just in parenthesis you remember
you thought he could define causation
in terms of temporal order
in terms of regularity and
in a way special relativity reverses the
order of bit and
says we know what a causal signal is
and how fast it can travel and that will
tell us
in which areas of space time we can talk
about a definite temporal order
but um
[Music]
so the problem of entanglement and the
compatibility problem
that it raises um confronts us
with with two aspects of causation
one is that it is conservation laws
that explain for us the correlation
we don't want to violate certain
conservation laws
and the other is that we worry about the
conflict
with a theory which is causing throwing
through in a very strong sense
and as i will proceed to explain i don't
think there is one
sense to the notion of causation but the
theory
of special relativity is the cause of
theory in a very strong sense
so what can be done about this
so a number of thinkers
um i'm thinking primarily of you
price have come up but he was not the
first one and he's not the only one
and one of his has a nice formulation of
quantum mechanics that
is similar and to what price
had in mind and he's you know he's a
physicist a philosopher
so instead of talking about particles
and their correlations we couldn't
we we can um think analogously
about two twins
and they are this is again very familiar
it's not
my translation into this scenario
but they are presented with a series of
questions
and we find that their questions
so somewhere in their future there is
someone
asking them these questions and we find
that their
answers are more correlated than we
would expect
if they that just answer randomly
and so we say well we have here some
kind of correlation
it's not random there must be some
common cause so
probably the twins have a kind of
genetic
property that ensures
they're replying to certain questions
in a certain way now according to what
we just said
ben's inequalities and the whole problem
of entanglement
is that if we assume such a common cause
or we assume that hidden variables
we get into conflict with quantum
mechanics and the violation of bill's
inequalities were confirmed by
experience many many times since the 80s
so if that's not a possibility if we
cannot go
the left um
schema of a common cause to the
correlation between the two twins
their new prices why don't we go in the
other direction
and suppose that by asking these
questions the questioner
causes or
um acts upon the twins
making them giving them the property
that will yield
the correlation between them so rather
than looking for a common cause in the
past
we look at something in the future that
whose influence goes back and explains
the correlation so this of course is a
very
very radical idea because we haven't
encountered anything
like rhetoricalization
um in our daily lives and
um so this possibility sits there
and i i want to ask later whether
one takes it to be only an epistemic
possibility
if we know what the answer was we could
go back and
calculate probabilities or if this is
supposed to be
something about physical reality
but anyway it's a very radical solution
and uh what we heard yesterday
is certainly um
a kind of spin-off from that
um root
uh of that approach where we say
look why are we so tied
to the classical picture where the past
influences the future
but the future never influences the past
perhaps
we should give up this assumption
so should we give up causal asymmetry
or temporal asymmetry because the two
are related and as i said
sometimes we see causation is parasitic
on temporal order and sometimes it's the
other way around there's in special
relativity i
think um
so according to price according to
some other philosophers and according to
uh elise yesterday this is indeed
a lesson with we should draw and her
approach wasn't based
on a price's argument or on retro
causality
but it was based on these very
recent arguments theoretical arguments
and very recent
experiments that seem to suggest i want
i i almost say demonstrate but the
experiment but
let me be very careful seem to suggest
that
this is really a very fruitful approach
to take
and i want to emphasize that the idea
here to relinquish
the causal order between past and future
applies both according to price
um and according to at least to
the fundamental level of physics and um
they don't on and the other philosophers
have argued in their direction
and i think even carlo rovelli in the
first lecture
of the series which i listened to um
with great pleasure
and so we're talking about the
fundamental level of physics and say
here there is no temporal direction
or no or no causal direction
and the question of why we get the
impression that there is such a thing
on higher level is a very big questions
and i think
we should get to that question in the
discussion
so this is one thing i want to note
about yesterday's suggestion and the
other thing is more important
because you see there was this argument
for years and years and years
that the fundamental laws of nature
are time reversal symmetric they don't
distinguish
the fundamental laws of nature do not
distinguish
between past and future no error of time
at the fundamental level of physics but
i always
felt that there was a gap in this
argument and
to conclude from the time reverses
symmetry of the fundamental laws
that there is no temporal order in
individual processes seem to me
a big jump because it could be that all
processes can go from one direction to
the other and also from the other
direction to the first
like we can blow a balloon and fills up
with air and then
we deflate it and it's again this little
piece of
rubber and both can happen
but in each individual case we could
think
supposedly in each individual case we
can say
by pointing to initial conditions or
whatever we could say
what the direction in this individual
case was
so it seemed to me that there is a gap
in the argument from time
uh reverses symmetry of the fundamental
laws
to no temporal order on the fundamental
level or no
causal order fundamental level and what
was what i found so
fascinating about the
results that elisa presented yesterday
was that here we're talking about
individual processes
we're not rehearsing this older argument
about the fundamental laws and yet
we should note that the asymmetry
in question is but one of the
characteristics
traditionally associated with the notion
of cause
so even if we give up this
asymmetry
this doesn't mean that we give up
causation in january so
giving up the asymmetry
of the chordal relation the temporal
asymmetry of the chordal relation
doesn't mean that we must give up
the notion of cause and here i'll get to
my first question
so interpose
imagine it's causation and augment
marked way
speaking to you and the reports
of the disaccusation are greatly
exaggerated
on my view so why is that can you hear
me
yeah so here comes my first question
question and it goes to you elise but it
goes to other people who have written
about it
are we talking about the principle of
causality
i think you mentioned such a principle
in your talk yesterday
or are we talking about a concept the
concept
of cause and so just to show you that
people confuse the two and later in the
discussion
discussion maybe i could explain why so
here's russia
the word cause is so inextricably bound
up
with misleading association as to make
its complete exclude extrusion from
the philosophical vocabulary desirable
and that is after criticizing the
principle of causation so he concludes
no principle
no concept
and much more recently jonathan of
course
says centuries of failed attempts to
formulate
a principle of causality robustly true
under the introduction of new scientific
theories have left the notion of
causation so plastic that virtually
any new science can be made to conform
with it
so i think it's a big exaggeration
it's not so plastic it's not so easy to
construct a new theory that follows
constraints that you wanted to cons to
follow or to satisfy
but what i pointed here is the confusion
between the principle
and the notion
and um i don't know what the principle
of causality is
um in the sense that there are at least
two
formulations of the principle of
causality and they are not
synonymous and they're not even
extensional so but again i skip that and
i can answer
i can explain why i'm saying that later
in the discussion but anyway i
don't want to suppose that we endorse
or oppose the principle of causality
what i do want to suppose or to propose
well first so now there are many
definitions of possession there is a
vast philosophical literature
people are working on causation and
whether it's a union definition whether
it's david lewis's definition whether
it's a
energy transfer or whether it's a
probabilistic definition of causation
many competing definitions in the field
but they
all refer to the causal relations
between
individual events and each one have its
problems and each one can be patched up
but i don't want to follow this
a well-charted route
what do i want to suggest i suggest i
have suggested it
already i cannot pretend that it just
occurred to me yesterday after ellis's
talk
so i suggest looking instead at
more general constraints which
in my view comprise the notion
of cause so what
is a causal constraint in my view
a causal constraint is a constraint on
change it tells us which changes
and processes are possible
or even necessary and now less
important in my view which changes are
impossible and
um if if you go back to the
philosophical literature
about causation for example
what word intervention this sort of
thing then
they they are often very good at
explaining
why something happened but they're
not so good at explaining why something
didn't happen
and i think that in science it's crucial
for us
when we think that something can happen
but we never find it
we never find two electrons in the same
level we want to know
why and it's a methodological principle
that we should find
a law or a constraint
that excludes
this option that we thought was possible
but we don't find it and that's why i
think
if the language of causal constraints is
much better to explain
what doesn't happen and i think it it's
crucial for science to think both
about what happens and about what
doesn't happen
so uh yamima i just have a quick
clarification so
um a causal constraint then
by this definition is intimately related
to the idea of the counterfactual
right or um
it is but you know this is not
the basis of the definition because
because there are definitions of
causation where they're saying
a cause is a necessary condition which
means that if it hadn't happened the
effect wouldn't have happened
but i'm not saying that i'm saying a
conservation law is a cause of
constraints
so yes if they wouldn't if we wouldn't
have the conservation of energy
energy we could build a perpetual
mobility machine so
almost everything we say supports some
counter factors we say something
positive
and it supports some counter factors and
i'm full counter factors i have no
problem with counter factors even in
history but
but this is not the definition this is
not the defining correct diversity
but perhaps we should we should pause
for a moment in this notion of
change because you know from antiquity
philosophers have argued like fermented
is saying there is no change in your
clients are saying everything
has changed you cannot step into the
same river twice
and we today have a kind of synthesis
between those views we say
yes there is change in the world but not
any change we have constraints on change
why do i think that this is important
for physics because
unlike mathematics there are
mathematical constraints in physics
of course but the physical constraints
that are
not mathematical in my view are
constraints on
change mathematics doesn't have a notion
of change
and so i think everything that governs
change don't take the metaphor of
governing too literally but everything
that tells us
which changes are possible and which
changes are not possible has to do with
causation
now i know that i'm vulnerable here to
what quine used to say by denying the
doctrine one only changes the subject
so in a way i change the subject because
i'm not talking only about causal
relations between
events and i want to broaden the picture
but
i think i have motivated um
my wish to to broaden the picture
and i'll say more about it in a minute
so examples of constraints and i want to
emphasize that none of them is a priori
we have to check in each theory whether
this theory
uh satisfies this constraint and we
check it
empirically so we don't impose our
constraints but there are
constraints that we um that have gained
our credence and we rely on them and we
use them to build new theories they are
symmetries that we use to construct new
theories
we trust this symmetry and we think that
um
our theory should be generally
convergent or we think it should
follow some other symmetries principle
of relativity or whatever
so here are some examples of constraints
determinism
locality and again
i i emphasize they they can be disproved
maybe the fundamental theories are not
deterministic maybe some theories are
some theories or not but there are
constraints
that have been used and that we should
consider
and that are part of the cluster
fam cluster notion of cause
the other one is locality we've talked
about this in the beginning
and yesterday of course there are
symmetries and conservation laws
which are very important they are high
up in the hierarchy of physics
there's queries principle which tells us
that every symmetry
in the cause has to be in the effect but
it uses
causal noses we can formulate it in
terms of the
equations and solutions we can formulate
it in various other ways that
do not presuppose a notion of course we
have in various principles which
are again very high up in the hierarchy
of physics symmetries and in various
principles and there is a connection
between them but we don't go into that
um and stability sometimes not always
it's very important i think the notion
of stability like the notion of
necessity and contingency is very
important in human life again
i'm not stopping to discuss this notion
here but just remember that
when war was struggling to construct a
new
model of the atom he had to comply with
what we know about atoms that they are
very very stable
and the classical model wouldn't give
him the stability and therefore he had
to assume all kinds of assumptions
about stationary state they do not
radiate et cetera et cetera
so sometimes stability is also a causal
constraint
and there are and these constraints i've
dealt with in my book but there are
constraints there are the constraints
that are
in any way i didn't think in the book
that i had something very new
to say about them and i was also
indecisive about them
and one of them is causal asymmetry so
one reason i didn't want to spend much
time on it
in the book was that matthias fishes
just published a year of two years
earlier
a book entirely dedicated to causal
asymmetry and the other reason was that
um i don't know i think it's
it's too open at the moment how much of
a constraint is it it's not something
that
usually would be considered a
constrained that
would tell us what kind of theory we
should construct it's not like the
principle of relativity it's not
like least action it's not like these
well-established principles and
yesterday
we had we heard of very recent reasons
of why it's not just such a fundamental
principle
and there is another interesting
principle and it may even be
somehow related to this principle which
is a mutuality of cause of action
which means that if here we are talking
about events
if if the cause acts on the effect the
effect
also acts on the cause and you could say
this is newton's
third law but um
and in that case it's certainly a causal
constraint but um
you know einstein used it
as a justification even if it was a
justification
after the fact for justifying dynamical
space space-time because he said there
was something very unsatisfactory
causally unsatisfactory in newton's
theory
because here we in newton theory we have
space
and space acts on matter because
acceleration relative to space has
physical meaning
but we don't have matter acting back on
space
and in my theory in general relativity
we we have matter
acting back on space so this restores
the symmetry so this was a line of
argument in einstein in
22 wasn't mentioned in the
in 1922 wasn't mentioned in the 1916
paper
and so it may be something that occurred
to him afterwards but again
it's a kind of constraint some sometimes
it
it we think it's a
it's a merit of a theory if it obeys it
but it's not something that fundamental
okay so why the causal constraints
approach why do i prefer it although it
has this problem of changing the subject
somewhat
so first of all i think this is how
scientists think i think very rarely
scientists think about the case of two
people who you know
trying to murder a third one and one
punches a
hole in the water flask and the other
one puts poison in it and then who's
responsible et cetera
this is not the kind of question that
worries scientists but scientists want
to worry
they want to to know about basic
symmetries
basic invariance laws so i think they
are more
useful to think about in the context of
scientific reasoning
there are also historical reasons
because if you think of it
conservation laws
there were ancient ideas about um not
creating anything for ex nihil so to
speak
and that nothing gets lost back into the
void
so there was this idea of conservation
there was
um an idea that the cause equals
the effect so it's in some sense there
was
there are historical routes to the idea
that conservation laws
are a causal constraints and you have
people like
merson and even boar bor when war talks
about
causality he actually talks about
conservation laws
and again i won't go into it here but
elise probably knows because she writes
a book or she has written a book on the
history
of quantum mechanics and other
philosophers like emil morrison also
thinks the conservation laws are very so
there are historical reasons
they are as i said before a causal
constraints explain what we do not find
and that's an important function of
causal constraints
but the fourth reason for me
and this does not depend on changing the
subject it's not a semantic issue
and that this approach of the causal
constraints
opens a variety of questions about the
relations between
different constraints so
um when we only have one definition of
causation and we think that's
the definition etc we don't think very
much about the other definition but
when we see that we really have a family
of several constraints and some perhaps
are more fundamental than others some
perhaps are reducible to others
and some perhaps
we tend to confuse and we shouldn't
and then there is a lot of work to do so
some of these relations are well known
for example um cemeteries and
conservation laws are related it was
already people became aware of it in the
course of the development of classical
mechanics and then of course they are
the important theorems of eminate
natural so
symmetries and conservation laws are
closely related
this is well known there are other cases
there are things that
we seem
or conceive of as very closely related
and they are not so closely related
for example determinism
and necessity or determinism and
stability
or again in more
everyday uh talk determinism
and fatalism there's a big difference of
whether one event
is very stable and no matter where you
start
you're going to get to it or whether we
just have determinism
um and
there is another option also we want to
disentangle determinism and necessity
and stability
we also this is also a nice um
case where we should disentangle notions
again in the philosophical literature
you have
a definition of causation in terms of
absolute determinism
but then there is a competing definition
in terms of intervention right
causal model theories are based on this
idea of intervention
now when you think of it when does
determinism apply
determinism only applies in a closed
system
an intervention is always an
intervention from
without so actually there is a
tension between causation as
intervention
or as manifesting itself in a case of
intervention
and determinism where you have a closed
system and
once the initial conditions are given
nothing can change
and so when you think about the
different
members of this family of causal
constraints you can
you can be more sensitive to these
differences
and there are cases and here we get to
quantum mechanics
where there is really a very fascinating
dance between different constraints
and a dance or payoff relation that was
not evident from the beginning and if we
go back to the
epr situation that we started from
which gave rise to the idea of
entanglement
here we have a very peculiar
payoff relation between determinism
and locality because
it turns out that the reason
we can comply with a no
signaling constraint that gives us
compatibility with special relativity
is that neither alice
nor bob can predict
the results of the measurement with
certainty
so it's because when they look at what
they do
they cannot infer with certainty what
the result at the other end
was that there is no signaling
because if there was determinism they
could have used
the correlation that they know in order
to signal
so here we have an example of if you
think of it location is what
locality is one constraint and it talks
about how
causal inference spreads in space time
which would be continuous etc
and it should take time and determinism
is something else it tells us that
if we have the same system again it will
develop exactly in the same trajectory
and on the face of it we don't see the
relation between the two and in
classical physics it's not clear
how this relationship works but in
classic classical in quantum mechanics
it's a very intricate relation
so
we can now go back
and we may discuss several questions and
i want to say something
about the last of these and so these are
not
we don't have to discuss them but these
are just
suggestions for what we could discuss so
i
asked elise yesterday and and i would
like to hear more about it
how she characterizes her view
vis-a-vis these other views that claim
there is no cause of direction on the
fundamental level of physics in
particular there is no
causal um asymmetry
um at the level of quantum mechanics so
we
if and where in this view differs
because the metaphysical part of the
talk i wasn't so
sure that i'm following
the point where you think these
new results really make a difference
to what the other people who say there
there's no causal order no temporary on
the fundamental
level i couldn't i wasn't sure that i
see the exact difference between
your conclusions from the experiments
and from the
theorems you reported
and the point you were trying to make
the other question which we didn't
discuss yesterday but
you mentioned at least the possibility
of an epistemic interpretation of what
we see
and i wanted you perhaps if if you'd
like
to expand a little bit on that
would it make a difference what kind of
difference would it make
epistemic interpretations of quantum
mechanics are quite influential
and i wonder whether
you want to say a bit more about it i
know you mentioned it yesterday
the third one is whether free will
is particularly problematic for
um any view i here i wrote regular
causation but in general for every view
that
allows an influence from the future to
the past
i deleted apparently question number
four because we started to discuss it
yesterday
and so um the last question
to me is the most troubling one
and i want to say something about it and
the question is how does
causal order emerge on higher levels
because we agree that on higher levels
we do see
i suppose you would agree to that and
we do see temporal order and we do
we seem to see we have an impression of
temporary and of course an order
and we want to know if not how they
actually emerge
how our impression
has been formed and has been has become
so stable
that we say well it's our intuition or
whatever it has become a very stable
kind of thinking
that something like that exists on
higher levels
and why do i think it's a big question
because
we don't know as yet very much
about the relationship between quantum
mechanics
and the higher level of physics like
let's say quantum mechanics is
the fundamental theory let's forget for
a minute about general relativity
let's say quantum mechanics is the
fundamental level
on the fundamental level there is no
causal order there's no temporal order
how does it emerge so i'm not talking
about
why entanglement disappears in the
classical world because there is a good
question to that
and you mentioned it yesterday and your
work
is some of your work
goes into decoherence in great depths so
dicohans explains to us why we don't see
superposition in
the macro world and that's fine but this
is not my question because causal order
causes asymmetry and temporal order
and somehow emerge
again either in reality or in our our
perception of reality
and we want to know how that happens and
that brings us back
to the era of time thermodynamics and
answer to that answers to that question
and i think um sometimes there are
good arguments but very often there is a
lot of hand waving
we live in the macro world and here the
second law of thermodynamics applies
well we know that's not enough
so we say yes but our universe is such
that the initial conditions were such
and
we are the result of this branch we're
sitting on that branch that started with
this particular initial conditions and
again i'm
not sure this is a very satisfactory
answer
and that it really explains the mixing
of coffee and milk
as we say um
in our cappuccino so
what am i looking for why am i
dissatisfied i want to give
one example that to me
is a paradigm of a wonderful case
and that's fineman's derivation and with
that i would conclude it's
my my last point and this is the kind of
idea that i want to set
for explaining the relationship between
quantum mechanics all the fundamental
level where there is no causal order and
the higher levels where there is a
pausing order
so farmland succeeded to recover
in recovery the principle of least
action
from his picture
of quantum mechanics and if you think of
it
there is something very surprising about
that because the principle of least
action and i said
at the beginning variation principles
are very important in physics
so they are very very high up in the
hierarchy of causal constraints
but the principle of least action and
its likes is a very strange
principle if you think of it because
neutron mechanics is okay right every
particle every every mechanical object
gets instructions every minute
and these instructions determine how it
would move
but a principle like
the principle of least action seems very
teleological
right because how can a system
pick a particular path that at each
point
satisfies a constraint of economy
or minimal value to a certain integral
it seems that it has to have the end
point
in view and choose a path it does
something
and this this is ridiculous this is
completely technological and
we we want to get rid of this kind of
formulation
in physics right so okay
then people prove that the principle of
least action
and the formulation of classical
mechanics in terms of newtonian
differential equation our
equations are equivalent and we can view
it as either completely causal alan
newton
or um etiological with the principle of
least action since they are equivalent
we don't have to
place too much weight on either of these
perspectives
um the causalist will say that the
ideological
explanation is a superstructure on the
causal explanation and if some
someone likes teleological explanation
you would
reverse a picture and say that the
causal structure
is a superstructure on the teleological
structure
fine but then comes quantum mechanics
and it's all probabilities certainly
according to feynman
how can we recover the principle of
least action with this
teleological appearance from the
underlying
chaotic reality of quantum mechanics
and feyman managed to do it
and there is a calculation there is a
derivation
he had a hint from iraq
as to how to define action in quantum
mechanics what is the analog of
classical action in quantum mechanics
he was looking for it for a long time
then he got this hint from
a student who came over from europe and
told him about it and within hours
as they say this is a story he derives
the schrodinger equation etc etc so
he formulated quantum mechanics in
lagrangian terms
and in terms of the principle of least
action which was which was
his favorite formulation anyway
even in work that he did before so this
for me is a model
of deriving something macroscopic
and curious and
inexplicable on the face of it
in quantum terms and to derive it
from the underlying reality of
quantum mechanics
so what i would like to see not that i'm
hoping for
one of us to do it tonight but but i
think this is a model
that would not be just hand waving we
sit here
in the microscopic world yes we sit in
the microscopic world well what is the
relation we have to find some continuity
between this fundamental level at which
there is no causal order
and the higher levels on which there is
so
any of these points or other points that
you want to
react to elise i'd be delighted
well thank you so much yamima um there's
just so much goodness there um
i wrote notes and notes and notes while
you were speaking so i will say very
briefly
and then um sort of respond to a couple
things and then
let others weigh in and we can see where
the discussion goes what people find
most interesting
um but the first thing i want to say is
that i find your definition of causality
as a constraint on change
to be i think among the most robust
definitions i've encountered where
causality is not at the fundamental
level indeed constraints are not
they're sort of meta properties right
they're properties about how properties
can be
and i find it extraordinarily helpful
and so i really like it but what i think
indefinite causal ordering
experiments are doing is putting to test
what happens when we drop a sort of our
what we assume to be the correct
constraints
for the ordering loosely ordered uh the
loose ordering
of certain events or certain operations
and
what they find is actual fruit right
not just that not just um greater
efficiency in quantum computation
perhaps but there's also a suggestion
that
it may guide how we think about
quantization of gravity
um by thinking about these things so
in a way um somebody had asked yesterday
i think it was
fair fast um or or maybe with peter how
i moved from deep appearance to this
well decoherence is exactly
the rich studies that come out of that
are based on realizing that
we only do quantum mechanics in the
first place as you said yamima
by invoking certain assumptions or
idealizations about
the closeness and isolatedness of the
system of interest
that we can carve the world up in
certain ways and this is the apparatus
and this is the system of interest and
there's the environment
and we can neglect the environment and
so on and we can pretend that
schrodinger's equation really unifically
evolves right and unitarily right
univocally and unitarily so there's
deterministic aspects there
um but that's you know that's not true
anytime you have an interaction
you have uh non-unitary uh
terms introduced right so i think
um even if i agree with you totally
which i do about this definition of
causation
there's there's two things the one is
that well
one of the arguments for um maintaining
a robust
understanding of causality at higher
levels
and i i take it that you said you
disagree that there
there is no causal principle you think
right no universal causal principle
i think we agree about that that seems
pretty clear
the question then is okay how do
how do we get usefulness for the clearly
useful clearly fruitful higher level
concepts but at the same time the fact
that it is by
dropping the concept of causality by
dropping a presupposed background
dependence
on a particular structure um
so for instance change right change
requires that you parse up a phase space
in a certain way
and look at how the system moves through
contiguous cells in that phase space
so ico i take it um
people investigating this are trying to
develop theories that
do not presuppose any parsing
of phase space or any parsing of that
space so they still measure change
but the change they're measuring is sort
of um
relative it isn't an ultimate it isn't
based in some structure of the world
that's truly causal or
has true different time points which is
exactly
what einstein as you mentioned why he
rejected newton's
absolute uh space-time cathedral right
the
or the theater in which these events
happened he wanted to drop that
absolute background uh and let the laws
of physics sort of
uh work within that and um i think
that that's a similar question here so
that's the first thing
is that thinking about causal
constraints could be useful
um but also how we can get around those
constraints
or untether the way those constraints
are moored to particular parsings of
space and time
because that's where we get change could
be very fruitful
too uh so that's that point and then
i'll end with a metaphysical point which
is again constraints
um they can't be primitive
can they i mean
are constraints a brute fact of the
world it seems that it couldn't be
because we have counter examples like
spontaneous symmetry breaking or i don't
know uh
parity failure and beta decay um
it seems that our symmetries and
there's a lot of literature about this
which i'm not totally um
up on and you may be but symmetry isn't
going to be our guiding light either
um and there is something they are but
they are not
sorry they are going to be or they are
not going to be
no guidelines they cannot be
i think because of these counter
examples
so they are very useful heuristics they
are very important for modeling and even
for developing new theories
but if we but they're they're useful as
guides but
problematic is dogma one might say
if you were talking about what does the
world really look like
i think constraints you either have to
accept them as a brute fact
the world just is the way that such that
momentum is conserved
or you say uh there's something deeper
going on and in this way maybe
maybe the debate here is a little bit
like
brown and pulley and others with their
lawrencian pedagogy it's like what do
you count as a brute fact
is it lorenzen variance that's a brute
fact of universe or is it the way the
metric
is uh and the sort of explanatory story
you tell
about how physics um how the other
theories sort of
rely on that under that um underpinning
depends on what you want to accept as a
brute fact in your in your metaphysic
so yeah thank you um
and and i want to think a lot more about
the retro causality thing i hadn't yet
um i i had taken hugh's work to be sort
of
um not not directly targeting the
asymmetry but if he is targeting the
asymmetry argument then i am clearly
aligned in some ways with what he's up
to so i will have to take a deeper
dive into that literature thank you
great um thank you so much
yeah sure please go ahead yeah yeah well
i
think i i try to make it clear that i
don't
see any of these as the in a dogmatic
way i see
i don't see any of these as a priori i
think our
our notion of the our our knowledge of
the world develops
and our uh notions our explanatory
notions develop with it we didn't we
didn't have a notion like general
covariance before general reference and
general theory of relativity and then we
had this notion
and what is beneficial so so i'm not
looking at
dogmatic a bit about any of these and of
course
we learned that some laws do not apply
and if you only think about
the history of the conservation of
energy so his thought equals mass
and then developing and we don't know
now what is dark matter priya can tell
us more about it so
we don't know where conservation of mass
energy would
lead us in the future these are open
things in our
i it's an open texture science is an
open texture and
our causal notions are open sector and
perhaps we'll drop
some of the constraints perhaps we have
drop determinism
i mentioned determinism but it's not
that i think the determinism
is still an accepted constraint so
sometimes we benefit from adding
constraints
like when einstein said i don't like it
that
that matter doesn't act back on space
let me add this constraint it should act
back then it has dynamical space
time and background independence and
wonderful so he added the constraint on
general covariance
on the other hand we gain a lot from
dropping constraints like dropping
determinism
some people say drop compatibility with
special relativity whatever so
it can work in either way and the last
thing i wanted is to
to be dogmatic about it but to the
contrary i want to say there is no
one definition of causation that the
philosopher can give
it's the way science develops they tell
us
now whether it's a root fact i don't
know what root facts
are unless you want individual effect
there is
the what what they call in philosophy
you mean supervisions all there is in
the world
are the fact and then there are our most
economical ways of stammering these
summarizing up this i'm not sure
that all laws of nature like
a conservation of energy for example
although it is as i said
the the future of this law is open um
i don't think we understand them as a
summary of what happened
we want to say don't invest in building
a perpetual mobile machine it won't
it won't work there is some kind of
stronger necessities
and just a summary of the facts and
so so i think constraints
are viewed by us in a different way
than facts but it doesn't mean that they
are not fundamental i don't know of
anything more fundamental in physics
than some basic symmetries
but it's all the feasible tomorrow we
may prove
wrong
okay yeah i'm sorry if i suggested that
you were being dogmatic i think i was
sort of
imagining metaphysicist metaphysicians
who would take your project on board
uh and want to motivate like a robust
sense of causality higher up and deny
fundamental causes
yeah exactly and i think i said this
yesterday too i mean you're very clear
in the book
uh by the way pick it up everyone
thank thanks for the promotion
um but but that you're not primarily
asking
metaphysical questions uh of this sort
but clearly you and i are most
interested in the
emergence kind of question and where
that emergence begins and where it ends
well where it ends is obvious it's at
the observable right but where it begins
will matter on your
metaphysical control of things to some
extent i might i might think
it does for me well i i can't separate
metaphysics from science that much
certainly not when i'm
not thinking about ethics but about
causation i think we learn from science
what the world is like and i don't think
that i have some other
means some access to a metaphysics
which i can judge whether it's right or
not
to help me understand science i think it
should
be bottom-up i should look at what
science does
and see whether it makes sense in some
more general way that you could learn
that that you would count or that other
people have counted as
metaphysicalization usually in
philosophy
belongs to metaphysics but to me it
belongs to philosophy of science
fair point so um
my that was that was wonderful um there
are a couple of questions
that we have from the audience and one
is from jen
geary who asks would degradation of
signal to noise
be another example of a constraint
that's how the quantum switch folks do
their work
it is exactly i saw that in the chat jen
that's exactly spot on um they are
thinking about signal to noise
constraints
in a particular way here i need to
understand better how that works but
uh yamima is that something you
encountered in your research for the
book
no and um it's
in what sense is it a constraint you
want to
limit it no it's something that you want
to
reduce
it's a pragmatic is it a pragmatic ideal
to reduce it's all
sorry i can let the i yeah jen if you
want to answer that you probably do a
better job than i can
oh in cybernetics i see um
well noises i mean it's related to the
the the fidelity of the
cubit in some stuff or the the the the
cleanliness of the
it has to do with information like what
what do you how do you parse
information right yeah yeah yeah and you
can think of the
the ico which is being about
establishing various quantum channels
and quantum channels is all about
signal-to-noise ratios
as far as i understand
so what what would the constraint look
like and can i
um that we should reduce the entropy
or the loss of information to a certain
degree and that quantum channels are
more efficient than
classical channels in that in doing that
or
uh let me see if i can remember um
it's it has to do on how they calculate
the upper and lower bounds for their
for that process matrix um the the
causal witness
so it's packaged right in at the front
and that's part of why i want to dig
into this more because the physics in
this case is not very clearly
telling us what's going on so
so yeah it's how they how they um
measure the noise to signal ratio
has to gives them allows them to set
those bounds on
when the process when the when the
causal witness
is witnessing um
a group of events that are separable
causally or nonseparable causally so
their whole definition of
separability or entanglement as it were
non-separability entanglement
is based in the signal tonight's measure
i see
so i think jen follows up with another
question so
in law human actors perform acts without
thoughtful action or intention
well i knew this one about free will was
coming what might be the connection
between this precept
and free will uh well i think we both
wanted to
to leave open the fact that there are
robust and genuinely
not just useful but explanatory weighty
and maybe even
predictive notions of causality that
emerge
in for instance biology evolutionary
biology or what have you
um but yeah i guess if you're
if there is some notion of reduction
applied if you want to understand
what what the basic behavior of the
smallest bits and bops
are um then it seems that you do have to
i i have assumed a quantum
fundamentalism and that's
that yeah i should be clear like that's
that is an assumption i think i'm in
good company making that a sense but
that's a difference
you are you are in good company but i i
i'm not in that company can i say
something about that
yes just a thought there's a difference
between the quantum phenomena
and the current somewhat confused
understanding of the quantum phenomena
the anomalies in that understanding are
not essentially anomalies in quantum
phenomena
so you have a lot of theoreticians
talking about quantum phenomena in
different ways
and some of the anomalies in theory are
anomalies in
talk about quanta not talk about
not the phenomena not the quanta
themselves so you're
presuming to over come to offset
to sabotage some classical ideas of
of causality as energy transfer for
example
just on the basis of ideas in quantum
theory
which explain experiments that are
incompletely understood
so an incomplete understanding of
quantum phenomena
is producing ideas of causality that
offset
or undermine ideas of causality
which seem fairly well grounded in
thermodynamics or biology yeah
no i i disagree with this that's
empirical evidence
i mean for instance the first ico switch
test that was done by pro
putsyadolik they developed a system for
doing a computation that was more
effective when they built it this way
than the other so there's
that cries out to me as a philosopher
says there's something here worth
explaining
whether it turns out it's an anomaly or
not is further but yeah mima sorry you
you have been waiting patiently yeah no
no
um well i certainly don't want to
throw away robust causal notions in the
classical
level on to the contrary i think um
my constraints work well in classical
physics but
many of them even if not the causal
order as i emphasized
that i'm willing to be open-minded about
the causal order
with in view of these new experiments
but
there are more symmetries and
conservation laws in quantum mechanics
than in classical mechanics
so i think in in this sense some of the
constraints
are satisfied in quantum mechanics so i
don't think quantum mechanics is an a
cause of theory or theory which has no
causality
maybe then this is what what at least
a question at least opened
our eyes to maybe there is no causal
order there
but then the most more important
question is reduction
i'm not a reductionist i think
in order to have reduction we have to
translate the laws of the higher level
into the laws of the lower level and the
concept of the higher level
to the concept of the lower level and
the idea is that once we do that
everything will be explained but it
doesn't work that way
because we learned that very often a lot
of the properties of the higher level
are completely insensitive to
things on the lower level and therefore
it is preferable to use properties and
concepts
of the higher level to explain phenomena
that
happen on the higher level so i'm not a
reductionist
and this is also related to the problem
of free will
because in order to have an explanatory
law
we have to explain the explanation that
is
the the um phenomena that we want to
explain
we have to describe it in a way that
matches
the description in the law right if we
want to explain
why this boat is sunk we have to use the
way that it can carry
and the way that was put on it and it
will help us
understand why it couldn't float but
the name of the of the captain and the
shirt he had
on that they won't help us right so we
have to have the right description
and i think that um a lot of the
properties that we need for mental
activity are not physical properties
physics has nothing to say about all the
people
the group of people whose name begins
with a b
it's not a natural kind so we cannot
expect that physics will have something
to say
about that group of people in the way it
has something to say about electrons
and in the same sense i don't think that
physics can say
something about all the things in the
world that can be frightening
say there is nothing common in physical
terms to all the frightening
things so i think um even in a
deterministic world
there is some sense of freedom in the
sense that we cannot
explain and therefore we cannot predict
our actions because a description of the
action
doesn't match any natural kind that
a law of physics can be hooked to or
hooked on to
and it's the very limited sense of
freedom
and i think it may connect well with
what you said
but even in this limited sense
is is um
consoling because it can even be
realized in a deterministic world and we
don't know that our world is
deterministic but even in a
deterministic world we can have that
kind of
non-reductionism and freedom thank you
thank you so much so there's a question
from jenny wagner
another of our regular um seminar
attendees
uh and she asked to question number two
how do you interpret the poly exclusion
principle as a causal constraint
can two electrons never actually be in
the same state
ontologically for me i would be cautious
and say that this should only be
interpreted epistemically because we can
never prove this exclusion principle
so should we treat possible and
impossible constraints in different ways
thank you very much for this question i
suppose it's to me
yeah okay so paulie's principle is
really an interesting principle
because in its mature formulation it's
just a mathematical principle right the
wave function of this combination is to
be anti-symmetric
and from that everything else follows
about fermions in general
and i had a big argument with a very
dear colleague of mine who
died at the beginning of the pandemic of
coving virus and
and he said um paulie's principle is
a a demonstration that purely
mathematical principles
do work for us in physics but
i looked a little more into the history
of the principle
and its applications not so much the
history but the applications of the
principle so
there was a very nice application of the
principle early on
in 3132 i don't remember exactly by
chandra sakao
um who calculated um the mass
of a white dwarf the limited mass
beyond which it would collapse under its
own gravity
and so there is gravity pulling
inside and what is the force that pulls
outside
and it's really the result of paulie
paulie's exclusion principle
and only when gravity overcomes
that pressure towards
the periphery and when gravity overcomes
it and pulls the mass back
then then we we have the collapse
and the limited reach which i think is
around 1.4 of the mass of the sun
is still very much a priya if it's still
acceptable
very much there i mean and the
degeneracy pressure
is a real thing and also you know in the
laboratory when they make bose einstein
condensates
they are taking advantage of the
degeneracy pressure
that you get so these new states of
matter and stuff
okay so so in that sense here it works
like a cause of principle because it's
something that balances gravity so
gravity
again is very abstract and and powerless
principle is very abstract but it's
the applications of these principles are
applications to very concrete things
and then later many years later when
when they proved the mature form of the
theory and they had to prove it they
used what they call a micro causality
that is a
relativistic special relativistic
principle that
um parallel or analogous to no
signaling so again a causal principle
went into the proof of the theory
so even if um electron for us and other
fermions certainly don't have an
identity and we
we cannot uh track them and
find them in a certain place and say the
other one cannot get into this place
and the way the principle work works and
is applied is
i think in harmony with i considering it
because of principle of symmetry and
anti-symmetry
to cause a constraint
um thank you that was uh very nice and
that was a great example actually um
very impressive area
remember the 1.4 solar masses
that was uh that was great
so um are there any um other questions
if not you know i'd like to close with
one question myself
and i think that you know um
i wonder you know when we talk about
um determinism
and we talk about reductionism
i often have a difficulty
trying to see how they sit conceptually
with like the essential sort of
provisional nature of science
and that i know that the provisionality
so what
what i'm trying to get at is you know
the provisionality of science
what is knowable in nature
has two kinds of limits right so there
may be limits that are intrinsic to
nature itself that maybe it's not
knowable beyond
whatever right and the other is
our own kind of cognitive limitations
and tools and capacities right
so i was wondering how our
notions of reductionism
and provisionality of
i mean do they collide or do you see
them you know how do you both
see them i would love to hear a little
bit more about
how to think about them because these
are sort of conceptually
i i struggle with them actually have to
confess
where exactly do you see the connection
why should
someone's position on determinism
[Music]
dictate position on reduction
as i said i i think we don't have to be
reductionists
well i think it because they they they
conflate at the point of prediction
right about what kind of
predictions therefore you can make for
future behavior of systems
so if you have a deterministic system
then
you know you are able to predict fairly
well
although limited with current limits of
you know how much you how much is
knowable right
yeah and um reductionism
is i see the way reductionism matters
is there is a way in which you can map
one system or one set of problems onto
another one which is predictable which
was deterministic
even though this particular one might
not be right
i'm trying to search for a concrete
example but um i'm not as
sharp on the fly as you are you mean to
come up with a problem that would really
illustrate this um
well that's i think it's related to
models when
when you take one area as a model for
another area
and um as i say
determinism
only applies under very strict
conditions
of closed systems and
um
and even if determinism holds in the
classical world you know the
argument that he doesn't even hold it
the classical right
yeah like norton and irma have given
examples but i think the examples are
very far out and we don't have to take
them too much into account so let's say
for us the world is deterministic and
then we learn that there is a
more fundamental level of quantum
mechanics which isn't then again i think
it's
our methodological drive is to explain
how what we see is compatible
with what we know about the fundamental
level
and that in some cases we succeed in
some
cases we do not you know face
transitions it's such a complex
area we're trying to figure out these
phase transitions from what we know
about the fundamental level and we learn
a lot of
curious things about analogies between
different materials that behave in
similar
similar ways although there is it's not
the same mechanism
magnetization is not the same mechanism
as condensation
but there are it's a similar
mathematical structure
and similar fixed points and
so it's not a reduction to the
mechanisms of the fundamental level at
all
i'm not a reduction and determinism
i don't i don't think i have to answer
those questions together determinism
is a different issue and reduction
at least did you want to weigh in yeah
it's um
i i agree with what yo mema says
um but maybe from a slightly different
perspective i mean the way i could
maybe understand reduction and
determinism is the same as that they're
about
establishing a particular kind of
relationship between two relata
a before and after or cause effect
relationship
in the case of determinism or a higher
order lower order for reduction
um but my phd thesis was all about if
this depends on a well-defined
well-defined relata
then you don't get there are no
well-defined relata
um unless you're assuming closed
isolated
systems uh and this becomes exacerbated
at large levels and this is why you get
maybe as
james ladyman has said like you get
maybe an ontology
for biology that's appropriate to that
field of study and that
um genuinely explains uh
and so on but it doesn't reduce
to quantum mechanics yeah it's not
translatable
to quantum yes right
great thank you um are there any other
questions
um last questions from the
um audience
i don't see um any so i would like to
take this opportunity to thank
uh both the mima and elise for a
wonderful
session today and for a really nice
lecture yesterday
it was a real treat and um i personally
could have had this go on
longer and longer and hang on to both of
you and
kind of ask many more
questions um you know it's really
remarkable how sharp
and clear your understanding is both of
you
thank you so much thank you very much
big pleasure a real pleasure and thank
you elise i'm so glad we met
this very nice opportunity yeah and i
hope you lima and we are we are hoping
to have a workshop
next year hopefully the virus permitting
week hopefully we will see you in new
haven so
wonderful thank you very much i'm
looking forward to it
and i just want to say thanks to tai and
to guy and for our audience
uh for attending thank you everyone bye